hello everybody my name is mar BL and
welcome to one after another an asylum
Jam game entry in the indie horror
Development Area this actually is an
interesting game Jam because they're
trying to make horror games that don't
fall into certain stereotypes such as
insane asylums blah blah blah you've
pretty much seen pretty much everything
and no Slender clones not that they're
that awful but I'm going to play this
one because it's actually pretty highly
rated and I seem to be some pixelated
guy standing among he had to make this
48 hours so I'm going to not criticize
the pixelated style of the game which is
totally fine I've had played some
pixelated games that were some of the
scariest games I've ever played in my
entire life where am I oh hello okay
that's an ominous deep base going on
there so what am I doing as a shirtless
dude oh what space to hide do I need to
hide
soon is there a purpose to me
hiding hello what is this is there a
reason that some going to drop down
oo should I not stand in the light also
I must admit my shirtless bod seems to
exude a rather significant
glow it's very
impressive okay what am I
doing okay
stairs okay oh hold space to hide I
don't need to hide yet at least I don't
think
so
okay what's
that huh so I'm going to turn on my
volum just a little bit
here go [__] you what was that okay I'm
dead
then what the hell I
landmine bear trap was that what that
was GE oh it's randomized oh well then
this is going to be very interesting I
don't know what my objective is so I
don't know what I'm supposed to
do okay so I can hide there I got to
watch on the ground it's like The Evil
Within except it's the evil without my
shirt I'm trying to be
funny calm down heart okay we're good so
I don't know if I need to go up to get
out of this place also where the hell am
I going okay so that goes back down I'm
trying to be careful because I don't
want to step on another one of those
things again who knows what that could
lead to looks like a butcher's knife on
the table
there what the [__]
oh
oh oh god oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead pissing
balls okay that's how this game's going
to be ah oh you're you're a fun guy
you're
fun oh oh oh okay all righty so I need
to deactivate those things not that
there was any reason to go that
direction some very creepy lady is going
to be chasing me at some point I just
need to be mindful of my
surroundings and be mindful of where the
hell the creepy lady is I also have to
hold down hide space all the way to stay
in the place so that I don't get eaten
alive
I'm hearing some creepy
noises it's following suit along uh some
of the other themes that I've seen in
pixel8 horror games when they can't make
up with uh graphical Fidelity they
definitely hit hard on the sound design
and the sound design and horror is
everything I've said this many many
times but this one's got it also I got
the volume cranked up in my
headphones still don't know what my
objective is but I'm going to try to
make it damn one hit kill
everything what are you jeez you
run okay I'm going to go around cuz I
think I remember there being an upway
over here then I can go around him then
he'll never find me okay be careful be
careful don't step on nothing oh don't
step on nothing
hide am I
okay am I going to be
alive
oh
okay ah that good old Basse tone
again all right so this game's got some
heebies and jeebies some
creeps
squeaks all
right yeah Rumble it up Rumble it up
okay that's a dead end over there I
think I think I'm supposed to go up and
enough such that I get out of wherever I
am not that I know where I am I'm just
going to assume that it's not insane
asylum because oh God I thought I saw
something
but so hiding is superbly effective as
it
seems what was that also I want to
comment that not only is there like the
pixelated style but there's this overlay
of a textured pixel ated thing okay
let's just take this nice and calm go on
no
surprises no surprises please all right
no surprises I'm
on okay I just want to find the end so
that I can say that I beat this game
which is actually pretty well done I'm
going to rightly admit okay I think I
think I got to find another way damn it
I'm on like the edge of the map or
something maybe there was another way to
go over far to the left I I think when I
came out of a upstairs route I went
right because I got scared by the doad
and then I hid in the closet back so
yeah this is where I was so should be
right about right about here here's
where I came up
so watch out for Bear traps they'll
murder my
kneecaps uh okay so far so
good it keeps doing that little oh God
damn it where am I supposed to go then I
don't even know what I'm supposed to do
I don't even know if there is a final
objective to this game there may not be
so I'm going to blindly rush into danger
and say no I came down from there that
just leads to another dead end over that
way so I got to find another route up
because that one obviously is not
correct that's a new
sound should I be
worried too bad I'm already worried ah
God it's another dead end what is with
this is this a series of dead ends CU
I'm not supposed to go any farther up
then why would they have that I would
assume that because the lights are from
above that they want me to go up but
then again maybe not I don't know I
don't remember which way I've
gone oh it's dark in here oh it's okay
here's another route up let me just make
sure I'm pretty sure this is going to be
a stopped wall yeah that's a sto wall
because I think the level is only like
five wide so this should be a different
area though okay so that's the stop wall
so there's set boundaries on the right
and left that
means this should be unless it's not
different why is the light shining on
this anyway is that oh oh oh oh
oh
oh is that me is that
me that's me okay goodbye I'm I'm going
to run now I tried to run it wouldn't
go oh okay oh that's
cool that's cool that's really cool it's
a short little game obviously was made
in 48 hours the graphics aren't great
because it's pixelated but still that
was cool very brief short story succinct
tells it in visual style doesn't have to
do any dialogue at all all the story is
told in the environment and it's cool
that's all I got to say about this so
there's a bunch of other Asylum Jam
games that are still being made or have
been made recently and you can check it
out in the description below alongside
this game uh there's about a dozen a
dozen or so they may be good they may be
bad but they're all worth a try because
hey it's game developers trying to make
something cool and this was cool so
thank you all so much for watching click
the endit Tas for more videos that I've
done check out the scary games playlist
down below there's like 150 videos in
there lots of content for you to enjoy
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye oh that's
disgusting hi nice beard or is that just
the entrails of the fallen on your
face all the sounds I don't like them
[__]
no [__] [__]